Okay.
Good afternoon, everybody. Thank you for joining us on this very
beautiful afternoon, and maybe more importantly, finding the room.
So,
it's always a good
start. So we've been given a very grand title, Hematological
Malignancies, Undruggable Targets and New Frontiers.
And
... Okay.
There we go. And so, essentially what we were asked
to do was to think about a little bit of some of the high-throughput
technologies that have been developed, and how we
can use these in heme malignancies to not only identify
targets, but also to help to guide our treatments.
And so,
my name's Faith Davis. I'm a physician scientist based in
NYU
Langone, and I specialize in multiple myeloma.
We are joined by my two esteemed
colleagues. Dr. Pickman is the co-director
of the Heme Malignancies Program,
and is based in the Children's Hospital in Dana-Farber in Boston, and
she's going to talk a little bit about functional genomics and drug screening for
precision medicine in acute leukemia.
Whereas, Dr. Woyach is the director of the
Division of Heme at Ohio State University's
Comprehensive Cancer Center, and she's going to be looking a little bit
about some of these things with respect to CLL and
BTK inhibitors. So, without further ado, I'm going
to pass on to
our first speaker, which is Dr. Pickman. So, thank you, Dr. Pickman.
Good afternoon.
Yes, good afternoon.
I really would like to thank the organizers for the invitation to talk to you
today about some
functional genomic and drug screening approaches for precision medicine
in acute leukemia. As Dr. Davis said, I'm a pediatric
oncologist, so
I will focus on pediatric acute leukemias during my
talk.
Pediatric cancer has a very low mutation burden, as you can
see here, and this also applies to acute
leukemias in
pediatrics.
And so when we talk about precision medicine efforts and this idea of trying to
match therapy to the genomic
alteration that a particular tumor has, that becomes
very difficult when there are actually few mutations.
When we look at the targets that are
found in pediatric acute leukemias in T-cell
ALL, B-cell ALL, and acute myeloid leukemia,
these targets are often transcription factors, epigenetic
targets, or other targets that are
traditionally thought to be undruggable.
So, what do we do with that?
And I'll show you one example here.
This is
in the pediatric acute myeloid leukemia where the
disease is often
driven by somatic fusions that occur,
and with, again, relatively few other mutations that are
present. And you can see from the names of some of these subgroups,
these are often transcription factors, and again, are difficult to
drug.
But there have been a number of efforts that have shown
that if you can identify the
targetable alteration, and especially if it's a
fusion, this can really make a significant impact in
treatment of the disease.
And in acute myeloid leukemia, these fusions
define subtypes that are specific and
associated with their distinct risk
prognosis, and we alter therapy based on
the fusions that appear. But again, some of these alterations
are such,
like introduction of stem cell transplant, so not really
targeted therapies per se.
So today, I'll talk about
three potential ways that we can think about drugging the
undruggable. The first is using functional genomic screening
to identify dependencies in particular
leukemias
or other cancers for that matter.
The second is to think about surface target
identification in cancers. And the third,
drug sensitivity screening that can be done on primary patient samples
and becomes agnostic to the type of mutations that are present.
One way that I think
functional genomic screening has been really transformed
and has made these
methodologies available to people everywhere has been
through the development of the Cancer Dependency Map.
This effort from the Broad Institute, led by a
number of very talented scientists,
has over the last eight years, collected
over 2,000 models, cancer cell lines and other cancer
models. These models are profiled using a
number of various omic
efforts,
both genetic and epigenetic
profiling, and are subject to genetic and
chemical perturbations.
When this data is combined, the omic profiling with the
genetic and chemical perturbations and analyzed, this can lead
to a number of therapeutic hypotheses that can then be
tested.Over the last several years,
efforts led by Doctors Kim Stadlinger, Charlie Roberts, and
Paquita Vazquez has also expanded DepMap to
include additional pediatric models in the effort called PedDep.
So my first example actually has to do with T-cell acute lymphoblastic
leukemia. This is a very heterogeneous disease, and work from
Charles Mullighan's group has defined over 17 different
subtypes of T-ALL, each associated with its own prognosis.
And again, you can see some of the names of the transcription factors
here. We used the dependency map
to ask whether there are specific
dependencies that are present in T-ALL over other
cancers and found that one-carbon folate pathway,
as well as purine and pyrimidine metabolism, were particular
dependencies in T-ALL versus other cancers and other
hematologic malignancies.
This is a very simplified schematic of the one-carbon folate pathway,
which contributes significantly
to lipid metabolism,
methylation, production of purines and pyrimidines.
And you can see these enzymes, SHMT1 and SHMT2, which
can be inhibited by various drugs.
And we worked with a drug called
RZ2994 that was developed by Raize
Therapeutics.
When we looked in target T-ALL data, you can see that a
subset of T-ALLs, these are enriched in the
MKX2.1 subtype, had increased
expression of the one-carbon folate pathway, purine and
pyrimidine metabolism.
And then, of course, we needed to validate the SHMT1 and
2 as a target at a lower throughput.
Using CRISPR knockout, we found that in T-ALL,
loss of SHMT1 and 2 both were needed to
decrease cell growth and lead to cell death.
And in the mouse model of T-ALL, treatment using
the RZ2994 compound
also led to a decrease in
T-ALL burden in the bone marrow and the spleen.
So this is the way the functional genomic screening was able to identify
a selective vulnerability in T-ALL, and we were
able to validate SHMT1 and 2, members of the one-carbon folate
pathway, as necessary to impair growth
in T-ALL,
and showed efficacy of inhibition of SHMT1 and 2 in
T-ALL models.
My next example will take us to acute myeloid leukemia
and a particular subtype of acute myeloid leukemia that is
really only present in young children
that are less than four years of age.
This is defined by this translocation in
CBFA2-T3, GLIS2. So these are transcription
factors. This type of leukemia is
present in 20% of
children with acute megakaryoblastic leukemia.
These patients have few other mutations other than this
translocation. And you can see have really quite poor outcomes.
Work from Kim Stadlinger's group has
used functional screening to identify targets for
GLIS2 rearranged AML.
So here, leukemia cell lines expressing Cas9 and
characterized by this GLIS2 rearrangement were transduced
with whole genome CRISPR libraries and
passaged over three weeks and then sequenced.
What they found in three of the models that had the GLIS2
rearrangement was that these were dependent on
the JAK2 kinase, non-receptor tyrosine kinase, as
well as JAK1,
a related kinase. And both can be
inhibited by ruxolitinib, an inhibitor of JAK1 and 2.
So this was particularly exciting.
Again, they went on to validate this finding at low throughput.
So this is one of the GLIS2 rearranged models where loss of
JAK2 led to a decrease in leukemia cell
growth. And then in vivo, similarly, loss of JAK2 led to a
decrease in leukemia burden.
When looking at the survival of the mice, you can
see that loss of JAK2 led to some
prolongation in survival of these mice, but certainly
not cure.
And perhaps most importantly, we had a patient who was
treated,
who had GLIS2 rearranged AML and was treated with ruxolitinib and had
a response initially but then progressed.
And so that
really
speaks to the need for target therapies and perhaps some inherent resistance
to this type of approach.
So they then turned to functional
screening to try to address the mechanism of resistance
in these leukemias.
So here again are the AML cells with the GLIS2
fusion that were transduced with a whole genome
CRISPR library and then grown either with the
JAK1-2 inhibitor ruxolitinib or without it to identify
genes that are depleted or enriched in the setting of the drug.
Identified here were a number of genes,
and some were negative regulators of
the MAPK signaling pathway, like RASA2, for example here.
As I said, RASA2 is a negative regulator of the MAP kinase
pathway and RAS signaling, and inhibition of
RASA2 leads to increase in signaling through the RAF
MEKMEK/ERK signaling pathway.
And CRISPR knockout of RAS2 led to
increased signaling in the ERK/MEK pathway
and pathway activation.
And
cells that had loss of RAS2 and activated
pathway signaling were resistant to ruxolitinib.
So this can potentially inform, again, a mechanism of
resistance, and as we think about combination therapies,
a combination of
targeted pathways targeting the JAK pathway and the RAS MAP
kinase pathway in this disease may be particularly efficacious.
So to summarize this part
here,
functional genomic screening identified dependency on JAK1-2
in GLIS2 rearranged AML,
as well as informed mechanisms of resistance to JAK
inhibition and potentially formed effective
combinations that are needed to target really highly aggressive
acute leukemias.
And now to shift towards looking at
cell surface targets.
This is work that was led by Soheil
Meshanchi
in Seattle Children's and Fred Hutch
where they looked at gene expression from over
1,400 pediatric acute myeloid leukemia samples,
as well as 84 healthy controls, to ask what are
the differential targets that are expressed
on specific subtypes of pediatric acute leukemias and
are not present in
normal healthy controls?
And again, focusing on the GLIS2 fusion AML,
you can see that expression of the FLT1
receptor was really high in the GLIS2 fusion
AML compared to the other subtypes of AML that were
present.
So here's where perhaps they got
lucky, as there's
a compound, STRO-02,
that is a FLT1-targeted
antibody-drug conjugate that was being developed by Sutro for
treatment of ovarian cancer and endometrial cancer.
This ADC targets FLT1 and is
bound to a warhead.
In
mice, in acute leukemia models,
a model that expressed high FLT1, you
can see that treatment with STRO-02 led to decrease
in leukemia burden and significantly
prolonged survival of the treated mice.
Perhaps most importantly, given the availability of this
compound, there were 40 young pediatric
patients who were treated
on compassionate use protocols with STRO-02.
And the responses were really quite remarkable for this really, again, highly
aggressive disease, where over 40% of the patients
treated were able to achieve complete remission with low
minimal residual disease. For the patients who achieved
this MRD
negative status, you can see a really quite impressive
survival here.
So here, expanded profiling of cell surface
markers informed a novel target in this really highly
therapy-resistant leukemia
and brought FLT1 expression as a target
to the forefront as we think about ways to treat GLIS2
rearranged AML.
The STRO-02 compound is no longer available,
but this research led to the development of FLT1 CAR T,
which are being tested in patients with GLIS2 rearranged AML.
This is work being led by Katherine Tarlock and Corrin Summers
in Seattle Children's and Fred Hutch.
And I actually recently learned that FLT1 is also really highly expressed in
osteosarcoma, so the next phase of this trial will actually also
include patients with osteosarcoma.
So as the next part, I'll tell you a bit about drug sensitivity
screening and how that could be used to also inform
precision medicine efforts.
A couple of years ago
now,
we partnered with 15 institutions across the United States
to form the LEAP consortium to
study the feasibility of identifying targetable alterations with matched
targeted therapy for pediatric patients with relapsed, refractory, or
high-risk leukemias. This was a study and
consortium that was generously funded by St. Baldrick's Foundation.
And
what we found, you can see here
in the report of the first 153 patients that were enrolled, there
was really a paucity of
immediately actionable alterations.
The most common mutations that were found were actually ones in the RAS pathway,
so KRAS and RAS and PTPN11 most commonly.
We worked with Jeff Tyner's group in Oregon Health Sciences to perform functional
screening of primary patient samples.
Here, leukemia cells were exposed to a number of different compounds
at a range of concentrations, and viability was
assessed after three days.
Focusing on the RAS
signaling pathway, which activates signaling by the
RAF-MEK-ERK pathway and can be inhibited by MEK inhibitors like
trametinib and selumetinib, you can see that samples that had the RAS
pathway mutations were particularly sensitive to this drug.
But again, there were some without the mutation that were also quite
sensitive.A single drug is really unlikely to
cure acute leukemia. And for some samples where there were
enough cells, we were able to look at combinations, combining the MEK
inhibitor trametinib with venetoclax, a BCL2 inhibitor.
And you can see a trend towards combinatorial
efficacy. In acute lymphoblastic leukemia cell
lines, where we have more
cells available, unlimited cells,
we were able to test the combination of trametinib and venetoclax and show
significant synergy.
We then turned to a model of a highly aggressive
B-ALL, one that's defined by this
TCF3-HLF fusion. Again,
going back to the transcription factor
phenomenon. This is a rare subtype of B-ALL that
unfortunately is almost universally
fatal.
In the PDX model, patient-derived xenograft model of
this subtype of B-ALL,
once this leukemia was established,
the mice were treated with
venetoclax or imatinib, or the combination.
This was work done in collaboration and at
Sarah Taizan's lab at CHOP.
And you can see here that, again, the combination led to a
significant decrease in leukemia burden.
So here we were able to show that RAS pathway mutations present a targetable
alteration in high-risk pediatric acute leukemia and
used this drug sensitivity testing to
show that a combination of venetoclax with a MEK inhibitor may be
effective in high-risk B-ALL models.
Overall, integration of genomic profiling and drug sensitivity testing can
uncover therapeutic combinations, and there are a number of groups
now in the United States and in Europe that are working
very hard to try to bring this type of screening to
patient care and to really select therapies for patients.
So I'm hopeful that in the next years, we'll be able to actually
use some of these screening
approaches even more clinically.
So today, to conclude, I showed you a couple of examples of how
we can use functional genomic screening, surface target
identification, and drug sensitivity screening to think about drugging the
undruggable and identify,
perhaps not specific targets, but sensitivities of cancer cells that could
be used
therapeutically.
So I thank you for your attention. I'm really grateful, of course, to
the patients and families who participate in a lot of our clinical
trials in my lab, and a number of our collaborators
and funding sources. Thank you.
Oops. That's great. Thank you, Jana, so much.
We have time for some questions. There are two working mics
between these middle set of rows here if people have any
questions.
So, maybe I'll start. You mentioned
about the, in your first example, the
SHMT-
Yeah.
-being a target. Is that drug going to make it to clinic, do you think?
Yeah, so that
drug really had poor
availability,
and
there were some efforts to optimize it, but it did not make it to clinic.
There have been some other efforts to try to drug
SHMT1-2 or some of the related enzymes that are in that
pathway, like MTHFD2, for example.
So I am still hopeful that maybe over time we'll be able to
find ways to drug that pathway. And of course, the one-carbon
folate pathway is also one that's targeted by
drugs like methotrexate. So some of our earliest
chemotherapy. So certainly,
again, points to this pathway as being
really critical to ALL.
Excellent. And maybe a second follow-up question.
In the final example, you were
talking about the combination of
targeting RAS with
a BCL2 inhibitor. Did they do some work, or did
either yourself or your colleagues do some work about the potential
mechanism of action about that?
Yeah.
We have
not looked at
the mechanism for that interaction.
It has certainly been now tested also
clinically. But in terms of the mechanism, I
don't know.
Okay.
But it would be a really interesting study.
I know. Lovely. Thank you so much. That was a great talk. Thank you.
So we're going to move on to
CLL now, and I'm pleased to
welcome Jen up to the stage.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you also to the meeting organizers for inviting me to
present today. And I'm excited to talk to you a little bit about a
druggable target, Bruton's tyrosine kinase.
And we'll talk about BTK inhibitor resistance in chronic lymphocytic
leukemia, implications for therapeutic sequencing.
So these are the objectives for the talk today.So for those of
you who aren't as familiar with CLL or don't think about the B-cell
receptor pathway all the time, this is just a little schematic for you
of the B-cell receptor signaling pathway.
And so in a normal B cell, the B-cell receptor is ligated by an
antigen, and depending on the nature of that antigen and the
maturation status of the B cell, a number of things can happen that you
could get activation, proliferation, or even anergy or
apoptosis.
In CLL, there is very minimal interaction with the CLL
cell and the outside environment, although multiple members of the
BCR pathway, including BTK, are upregulated and
constitutively active. And this leads only, in this case,
to survival and proliferation through the AKT pathway and
NF-kappa V and the MAP kinase pathway.
The
first iterations of drugs to target
BTK are the covalent BTK inhibitors, the first-in-class
molecule ibrutinib, and then the second generation, acalabrutinib
and zanubrutinib. These three are all covalent inhibitors that
bind BTK at the cysteine 41 site.
And covalent BTK inhibitors are extremely effective in CLL and
really have revolutionized the way that we treat this disease as well as many
other B-cell malignancies.
On the left here we have the
seminal study of ibrutinib, the RESONATE-2 trial, which is
actually the only one that has been going on long enough to give us a median
progression-free survival. So here we have seen in frontline
CLL that the median PFS with ibrutinib is 8.9 years.
Acalabrutinib and zanubrutinib, the second-generation molecules, were designed to
be more selective for BTK, and with the
idea that this would increase the tolerability of the drugs with
less alternative target or off-target effects, and also potentially
be more effective as they are a little more potent.
These ones, the studies have not gone on long enough to give us a median
PFS yet, but with acalabrutinib here in the ELEVATE
TN study, we have a 62% progression-free survival rate
at six years. With zanubrutinib in the SEQUOIA study down here, we
have a 75.8% PFS at five years.
And then the covalent BTK inhibitors are also effective in relapsed CLL,
although the median PFSs, as you would expect, are not quite as long as we
see in frontline disease.
Here we have two trials that compare a second-generation BTK
inhibitor to ibrutinib. The ELEVATE RR study compared
acalabrutinib to ibrutinib in high-risk relapsed/refractory
CLL, and this study demonstrated non-inferiority of
acalabrutinib to ibrutinib. Down here we have the ALPINe study, which
compared ibrutinib and zanubrutinib head-to-head in an unselected
relapsed/refractory patient population, showing zanubrutinib to
be
superior to ibrutinib in terms of PFS.
And unlike the frontline studies where we see basically
all patients will respond and have durable remissions, in
relapsed/refractory disease, we do see increased relevance to our
traditional prognostic factors in the disease.
At Ohio State, we had the opportunity to take care of a lot of patients treated
with these covalent BTK inhibitors, and so a few years ago looked at
456 patients treated with ibrutinib
to look at baseline characteristics independently
associated with progression-free survival.
And using multivariable models, we see that higher Rai stage at
diagnosis, the presence of previously treated
CLL, a worsening ECOG performance status, higher
LDH at baseline, and increasing karyotypic complexity
are all associated with a shorter PFS with this drug.
So when we think about how patients do become resistant to the
BTK inhibitors in CLL, with covalent BTK inhibitors, the
primary mechanism of resistance is acquisition of mutations
in either BTK itself or in the immediate downstream target of
BTK, PLC gamma 2. And in general, we'll talk about this in more
detail, but in general, BTK mutations impair drug binding,
and PLC gamma 2 mutations activate downstream signaling.
So the first mutation that was identified is the cysteine to serine mutation,
C41S, and so this is at the binding site of the drug and actually
causes ibrutinib to inhibit BTK reversibly rather than
irreversibly. And we can see that in the experiments here.
Over here on the left, we have recombinant
protein, either wild type or C41, exposed to
ibrutinib in either a manner where you just give the drug continuously
or wash the drug out. And you can see that with wild-type
BTK, the first two bars here, it doesn't matter if you leave the drug in
or if you wash it out, you inhibit both BTK and downstream
ERK phosphorylation,
as you would expect for an irreversible inhibitor.
With C41S BTK, on the other hand, if you leave the drug in
continuously, the dark blue lines here, you actually still can
inhibit BTK and ERK phosphorylation to some degree, but if you wash
the drug out, that inhibition is abrogated.
We can see that in a patient sample over here.
So this is a patient who
was treated with ibrutinib. We have a sample at baseline and then at the time of
relapse, where a C41S mutation was detected.
And you can see, then we exposed the cells to ibrutinib, again,
wash out or continuous. And at baseline with wild-type
BTK, whether you leave the drug in or if you wash it out, you can inhibit
BTK phosphorylation. But in the presence of a C41S
mutation, if you leave the drug in continuously, you can inhibit BTK
phosphorylation, but as soon as you wash the drug out, that phosphorylation
returns.We also see that the PLC gamma
2 mutations, there's a number of hotspot mutations that have been
identified, but they mostly share the same characteristic that
they are a potentially activating mutation.
So in cell lines with two of the more common ones,
R665W and L845F, we see that
downstream phosphorylation of AKT and ERK
remains present even in the presence of ibrutinib.
We can see that in a patient sample over here, again, taken at the time of
relapse where an R665W PLC gamma 2 mutation was
identified. We see that we can actually still inhibit BTK
phosphorylation as you would expect with ibrutinib, but the downstream
PLC gamma 2 remains active.
Then this is looking at calcium flux here.
So when you add the IgM, you get calcium flux.
Green here is wild type BTK where you see
a calcium flux that then can be inhibited if you add ibrutinib
to it.
With either the R665W or L845F
mutations, we see both augmented and sustained calcium flux that
are not affected if you add ibrutinib.
Again, demonstrating that these are activating mutations.
So many centers have now demonstrated that these
mutations are present in patients where
patients become resistant to
BTK inhibitors. These are some data from a collaboration with
Pharmacyclics who made ibrutinib,
where we looked at samples from company studies for patients at the time of
relapse, and we divided those relapses into Richter's
transformation, which is a transformation of CLL to a more aggressive type of
lymphoma,
relapse which was typified by increased lymphadenopathy
only, where we did not see elevation of the lymphocyte count, or the
most common, where we actually see increase in the blood
lymphocytes at the time of relapse, and then looked for the presence of these
mutations. And you can see that when patients have increased
lymphocytes in their blood at the time of relapse,
81% of those patients had BTK mutations and
19% had PLC gamma 2 mutations. This is a little bit
lower in patients where we don't see elevated lymphocyte count
at the time of relapse.
The group at NHLBI with Adrian Wiestner has actually shown
that there may be a compartment effect to this.
So they were able to take samples from the blood, lymph nodes, and
bone marrow at the same patient at the same time point, and they found
that the allelic frequencies of these mutations are actually quite different in
these different compartments, and even sometimes you can see a mutation in the
lymph node, but not in the blood or bone marrow or vice versa.
So suggesting a potential reason why we see lower
presence of the mutations in the blood in these patients.
And then Richter's transformation is only rarely associated with these mutations.
So we know that their mutations can be seen at the time of relapse,
and actually then have been able to demonstrate that these resistance
mutations actually can be detected far in advance of relapse and can even
be evaluated prospectively. So here on the left, we
have some data from the NHLBI, on the right data from Ohio State,
where we took samples
from the time of
relapse looking backward, and were able to see that we could
identify BTK or PLC gamma 2 mutations at a median of 9 to
12 months prior to relapse, suggesting that there may be a window for
therapeutic intervention there before a patient actually would clinically
relapse on these drugs.
Acalabrutinib, the second-generation BTK inhibitor, has similar
mechanisms of resistance to ibrutinib.
These are data from the ELEVATE RR study, which compared
acalabrutinib to ibrutinib head-to-head.
And we actually found that there were higher rates of BTK
C41 mutations in acalabrutinib-treated patients compared with
ibrutinib-treated patients in this group.
However, more PLC gamma 2 mutations were identified in ibrutinib-treated
patients compared to acalabrutinib-treated.
We also saw emergence of a new mutation, T474I, which is a
gatekeeper mutation. And in this study, this was only observed
in acalabrutinib-treated patients, and actually was only seen in
patients who also had a C41S mutation.
Zanubrutinib is the newest of the covalent BTK inhibitors, so the data on
resistance is the most limited. This is a smaller study from a
group in Australia who looked at ibrutinib- and zanubrutinib-treated patients at
the time of relapse. They did find C41S mutations in both
ibrutinib- and zanubrutinib-treated patients, although more commonly in the
ibrutinib-treated patients. But actually found a new
mutation, L528W, which is a kinase-impaired
mutation, and this was primarily seen in zanubrutinib-treated
patients and only rarely in ibrutinib-treated patients.
So to recap, with our covalent BTK inhibitors, we do see
similar and distinct patterns of relapse of these BTK mutations.
So with ibrutinib, we see primarily C41 mutations in BTK.
With acalabrutinib, we see C41 and T474.
And then with zanubrutinib, C41 and L528W
mutations.
So importantly to this idea of therapeutic sequencing, we see that
even in the presence of relapse
after covalent BTK inhibitors and also in the presence or
absence of these mutations, we do see that the B-cell receptor pathway
remains upregulated and active. So this is
single-cell sequencing data from three patients at baseline and relapse looking
at
a BCR score, and you can see here that
compared to baseline at relapse, if anything, the BCR score is even a little
bit higher, suggesting that these proteins are still going to be relevant,
and importantly suggesting that repeated targeting of BTK may be effective
if you have a drug that can overcome these resistance mutations.And
so that led the way to the development of non-covalent
BTK inhibitors. There are a few in clinical development.
Pirtobrutinib is the furthest along, having received FDA approval.
Nemtabrutinib is in Phase III clinical trials, and these sort of typify
this idea of a BTK inhibitor that binds
reversibly rather than irreversibly and does not use that C481
site. So was hypothesized to be effective even in the presence
of C481 resistance mutations.
These two drugs are fairly different from each other.
So pirtobrutinib, as you see here from the kino map, is extremely
selective. And that has led to it being very well-tolerated as well.
And in vitro has similar inhibition with
wild-type and C481S BTK. Nemtabrutinib, on the other hand, is
actually a very non-specific molecule and is a pan-Src and
pan-Tec kinase inhibitor. This actually leads to it being
relatively cytotoxic to CLL cells, more cytotoxic than we see
with most other of the BTK inhibitors, and in this
experiment was effective even in the setting of ibrutinib-resistant
CLL.
So with pirtobrutinib,
I'm going to focus on pirtobrutinib here since it's the furthest along in
development. We do see very high clinical efficacy in
patients after treatment with a covalent BTK inhibitor.
So these are some data from the Phase I/II clinical trial.
On the left here we have a waterfall plot where you can see that almost all
patients had shrinkage in their lymph nodes when treated with pirtobrutinib.
The overall response rate here is over 80%.
Looking at progression-free survival on the right here, the median PFS was
19.6 months. So a very effective drug, although
the durability of that efficacy in relapsed CLL is not as
long as we see with the covalent
BTK inhibitors.
So at the same time that pirtobrutinib was being developed, there were people
studying what was leading to resistance with pirtobrutinib.
This is the first data to come out of that, coming from Omar
Abdel-Wahab's group. And they looked at
nine patients, I believe, who had relapsed on
pirtobrutinib and found that most of the patients had acquired
mutations in BTK at non-C481 sites.
So some of the more common mutations that were identified are this
gatekeeper mutation, T474I. Again, we saw that previously
with acalabrutinib-treated patients.
And then this kinase-impaired mutation, L528W, again
previously seen also in zanubrutinib-treated patients.
A number of other kinase-impaired mutations have been observed, and then
other kind of mutants of that gatekeeper site as well.
Importantly though, and interestingly, the C481 mutation, which
many patients came on to the study with, actually either
decreased in allelic frequency or even disappeared entirely in the blood in
these patients at the time of relapse.
So what do we do after non-covalent BTK inhibitors?
Luckily, people had already started to work on these BTK degraders,
which have the capability to overcome many of these BTK
resistance mutations that we have been seeing.
Two of the furthest along, there's a number of these in development, two of the
furthest along are Bexarotenoag and
BGB16673. And you can see here from their clinical
data in the Phase I clinical trials, they both have been extremely
effective in the setting of kinase inhibitor-resistant
CLL. Many of these patients have been treated with both covalent and non-covalent
BTK inhibitors, in fact. And with the
Bexarotenoag, the median PFS was 22.1 months.
With BGB16673, the 16-month PFS was
65.9%. So suggesting that, again, these are going to be
effective drugs but may not also give those
five-plus year remission durations like we
were seeing with the covalent BTK inhibitors at first.
So resistance to the BTK degraders is still being worked out for the
majority of patients, but one mutation has come up in a
few different clinical sets and has been looked at in more
detail, and this is an A428D mutation in BTK.
This has also been very rarely observed with other kinase inhibitors,
although not seen very often at all, but seems to be more common
with
these degraders. And this mutation actually unfortunately interferes with the
binding pocket and collapses that binding pocket a little bit, which
suggests that it will likely confer resistance to all of the
BTK kinase inhibitors and degraders that are currently in clinical
development.
So when we think about how we could use this information to sequence,
there is certainly a straightforward pathway that we can think about that may
be applicable to the majority of CLL patients, especially ones that are
older when they start treatment. And this is where you could use a covalent
BTK inhibitor in the frontline setting, continue it until
progression, which hopefully is going to be nine-plus years.
At the emergence of likely a C481 BTK mutation, you
would switch the patient to a non-covalent BTK inhibitor, hopefully get a
couple year remission duration out of that.
Likely acquisition or expansion of mutations such as
T474I or L528W, and then move on to a
BTK degrader. Again, maybe a couple year remission duration, and
then potentially developing mutations either at this
A428D or other sites.
And so this would,
in a perfect world, give you about 13 years of treatment for an individual
patient, and that doesn't even
use our other major pathway in CLL that can be targeted, the
BCL2 pathway. Although, of course, nothing is perfect, and there are
a lot of challenges to this
approach. And of course, there can be multiple mutant clones in an
individual patient. PLC gamma-2 mutations are
likely going to be a challenge with the non-covalent BTK inhibitors, though may be
overcome with the degraders. And then new mutations, maybe after
a BTK degrader, or mutations that can occur
in other parts along this pathway that may render other
drugs ineffective.So I think that there's
a few questions and a few kind of thoughts going into the future that may
help us to better understand how we could sequence for individual
patients, if we can use all of these classes of drugs, if we can use
combinations that might be helpful.
I think the first question that people are working on is whether these BTK
mutations disappear without drug pressure.
And this probably will depend a little bit on the type of mutation.
So with the C481S mutation, I showed you that with
pirtobrutinib, that can often decrease with treatment and even
disappear even at the time of relapse after taking pirtobrutinib.
But in studies looking at venetoclax after BTK inhibitors,
usually that C481S mutation persists even after treatment with
venetoclax.
On the other hand,
A428D and some of these other kinase-impaired mutations may
actually have less of a survival advantage in the absence of a drug than
a C481S or the gatekeeper mutations.
And it's a little bit less clear how much persistence we are going to
see in the absence of drug.
My guess, though, is that all of these mutations, even if we can't detect
them in the blood, will persist at some low level, so
probably preventing us from getting durable remissions by using
these drugs in a circle.
But you may be able to come back to a drug like pirtobrutinib
or even a degrader or something after treatment with another class of drug
and have at least a short remission duration.
And another question that is sort of top of everybody's mind
right now is what would happen if we sequenced pirtobrutinib first?
So this is because of two phase 3 clinical trials that were
presented and published at the end of last year, both looking at
pirtobrutinib in the frontline setting.
One of these is BRU-IN-314, which is a trial head-to-head of
pirtobrutinib versus ibrutinib.
And in this study, one-third of the patients were treatment naive.
And here we saw a superior overall response rate
for pirtobrutinib versus ibrutinib in the entirety of the patient populations
that were treated, as well as an even more striking trend
towards superior overall response rate in the treatment-naive subgroup.
Down here we have a Kaplan-Meier curve of the treatment-naive subgroup.
Again, the follow-up here is very short.
But we do see a trend towards pirtobrutinib having a longer PFS compared
with ibrutinib, which of course is really interesting to see in the frontline
setting.
However, we don't have any data yet regarding the emergence of resistance
mutations in treatment-naive patients with pirtobrutinib.
We don't know what the timing of those is going to be.
We don't know if they're going to be the exact same mutations that we see in
relapsed/refractory CLL.
We do know that some of these mutations that we expect to see, like the gatekeeper
mutations, the kinase-impaired mutations, may make sequencing of a
covalent BTK inhibitor difficult, although maybe not impossible, because it
does seem, at least in vitro, that acalabrutinib has some
activity in the kinase-impaired mutations, whereas
zanubrutinib has some activity in the gatekeeper mutation.
So we don't know, though, are we going to see as long of a
remission if we do things in that order?
So I think until more data emerge,
most of us would reserve frontline pirtobrutinib for the group of
patients who are either older, where you may think that they're only going to need
one or two lines of treatment within their natural lifespan, or those
that are frail that may not tolerate a
covalent BTK inhibitor quite as well.
So what about a dual covalent non-covalent approach?
And so instead of kind of sequencing the drugs, what if there was one drug that
could do both?
So there is a drug currently in development called rockbrutinib or
LP-168 which has this mechanism. So in the
setting of wild-type C481, the drug can bind
irreversibly, just like ibrutinib, acalabrutinib, and zanubrutinib.
However, if C481 is mutated, the drug actually has the ability to form
non-covalent interactions too
and extends pretty deep into the binding pocket and actually does not
interact with any of the other sites that we see resistance
mutations develop in.
In vitro,
rockbrutinib is effective in C481S BTK as well
as T474I and L528W BTK.
And here's some data from the phase 1 clinical trial,
just a waterfall plot showing you that there was lymph node
shrinkage seen in patients treated with multiple covalent BTK
inhibitors, with non-covalent BTK inhibitors, as
well as those treated with venetoclax.
And this drug is now moving to phase 3 clinical trials.
And then the last point I want to bring up is actually a kind
of big point of debate, and this is whether fixed-duration regimens might
prevent resistance mutations. So I showed you a schematic of what might happen
if you treat somebody with CLL for upwards of 13
years, expecting that they're going to be on drug that whole time.
As more and more data comes out with BTK inhibitor plus
BCL-2 inhibitor combinations, we see that this type of
approach is actually extremely active and may give patients the
opportunity to be on albeit a little more aggressive therapy for a little while,
but then have long treatment-free intervals between therapies.
We're relatively new in the idea of sequencing these types of fixed-duration
regimens, so I think most of the data is relatively immature in terms of what's
going to happen if you do this repeatedly.
However, all data suggests that you may be able to re-treat
patients with these types of approaches.
So
one of the studies that we have the most information from
is the CAPTIVATE trial, which is a frontline study of ibrutinib plus venetoclax
given for a year.
And there were 25 patients who, at the time of disease progression, had samples
available. No mutations were observed in either BTK or PLC gamma
2.15 patients were retreated with
ibrutinib, and all of them actually responded to the drug.
And anecdotally, that's what we've seen in the setting of other fixed-duration
regimens like this as well, where after the patient relapses
after their first treatment with either a doublet or a triplet, they can generally
be treated with either BTK inhibitors or BCL-2 inhibitors with
success.
However, I think we would all expect that if you
do this type of approach, you're likely to have a shorter remission duration each
time, and we may in fact see the emergence of these resistance mutations with
repeated exposure.
So to conclude, resistance to BTK inhibitors will be a continued problem
with continuous dosing. Development of alternative kinase
inhibitors and degraders does currently allow for
sequencing for many years for most patients, with the caveat that
many of these drugs are not yet available commercially.
Fixed-duration approaches may further prolong drug sensitivity, allowing
therapeutic options that may extend for many patients' natural lifespan.
But I think continued work is necessary, especially to find effective strategies
for high-risk patients where these timelines are probably not accurate, as well
as for younger patients, where a 13- to 15-year approach is really not going to be
good enough.
So with that, I will end. And for the work done at Ohio State, I'd
like to acknowledge our CLL clinical and research team, as well as the
Experimental Hematology Laboratory, our collaborators,
and our funding sources. And I'd be happy to take any questions.
Thank you so much, Jen. Does anyone have a
question at this time?
Thank you for the excellent talk.
I was wondering, you talked about how a mutation upon
exposure to BTK inhibitors turns
the nature of
inhibition from reversible to irreversible.
If you could elaborate on how does the
structure of the receptor change to cause
that kinetic change?
Yeah. I
don't know that I can fully explain how the structure of the receptor changes,
but it appears that that mutation just inhibits or
changes the binding kinetics such that,
well, obviously instead of being irreversible, it's reversible, but the binding
affinity is lower. And even the idea of the reversible binding there is
relatively short, so all of the covalent inhibitors have very short
half-lives, so when you change it to a reversible inhibitor, it's clinically not
going to work anymore.
Understood. And another question about this
idea about only treating patients with a
fixed duration.
How do you think physicians and even patients can grapple with the
idea that
even if the disease has not completely entered into remission
stage, you just stop the treatment because that's the
paradigm, and then you start once again to reduce the
probability of resistance? Are we risking
the possibility of the disease itself taking over rather
than it coming back due to
resistance?
Yeah. Actually, that's a really important question.
And I should mention that the response rates to the fixed-duration
regimens are upwards of 90% in the frontline setting.
So pretty much every patient who you're going to be
considering stopping at the end of therapy, they will be in a remission.
And actually, even with these types of
therapies, especially with triplets, but probably with some
of the doublets too, we're getting undetectable minimal residual
disease
rates of upwards of 50%.
And we see that the presence of minimal residual disease
in IGHV unmutated CLL, so the more
kind of activated group, the higher-risk group, that tracks with
PFS. So the presence of MRD at the end of treatment for
an unmutated IGHV patient
is predictive of outcome. However, in the patients who have mutated IGHV,
so the lower-risk group, we actually see lower rates of undetectable
MRD in general. But it doesn't seem to matter, at least with
the data that we have, it doesn't matter whether they
have
measurable disease at the end of therapy or not.
Their remissions seem to be about the same and are very long.
So I think to your point, I would not
advocate treating a patient with a fixed-duration regimen and
stopping when they still have a kind of gross disease.
And there are a lot of studies looking at risk-adapted,
response-adapted, or MRD-adapted approaches, where you would continue
treatment until you get the deepest remission possible.
Thank you.
I think the resistance of BTK inhibitors,
the
reason is the continuous treatment, right?
If you have fixed-duration treatment, you would induce less resistant
mechanism, but continuous treatment ultimately will lead to
some kind of resistance.
So my question is, I don't fully understand the
philosophy or the rationale to develop something like
covalent and reversible,
irreversible in one molecule. To me,
first of all, it's relative, right?
It's only so-called reversible or non-reversible on
certain residues, not across the entire BTK,
right? So there will be ultimately resistant
mechanisms come out anyway.
So I think to develop a new molecule with that kind of
feature, does that really help? Or shall we just sequence the-...
reversible after the irreversible.
That will actually give you longer PFS instead of just a molecule has
both mechanism, but maybe they will induce some kind of
resistant mechanism
which all the existing BTK is not going to work quicker.
So I just don't know whether that's a smart way to do.
Well, I think that's really an open question, right?
So we don't know whether sequencing of those
drugs is going to be better than even if-- what if you were to give a covalent
and a non-covalent BTK inhibitor at the same time?
So let's say you treat it with acalabrutinib plus piratubrutinib, we have no idea
whether that would induce a longer remission than if you use the two drugs in
sequence. I mean, similar to giving acalabrutinib plus
venetoclax versus sequencing those drugs.
So I think that the idea that you would definitely
have a shorter remission with a dual approach is
unknown.
I think the pros of that approach would be like I said,
treating it or using it in a resistant setting already where we know
that some of the cells don't harbor
the C481S mutation, for example. So even if in a patient who
has disease resistant to piratubrutinib and a covalent BTK inhibitor,
the cells are not all the same, and they don't all have one resistance mechanism.
So a drug like that may be able to affect two types of cells
differently.
Can I ask another question?
Do you recall that whether the BTK degraders
people are developing,
can they overcome the PLC gamma 2
resistance, I mean, tissues?
Mm-hmm.
And if that's a yes, why?
Yeah.
So as to the why, I don't know exactly.
Actually, I have a grad student in the lab who's trying to look at that right now.
But it probably has to do with the fact that though we think about the BCR pathway
as linear, it's not actually linear, and there are ways that you can go
around BTK.
Whether they work, I think that the answer is probably yes,
although we don't really have that long of
follow-up, and we don't have that much resistance data available.
And one way that they might not work would be that
many times these mutations are at low allelic frequency, so it does take some time
for them to grow out. So I think yes, but I don't know.
Can I just ask a clinical question to close this part of
the session?
In CML, we would naturally sequence
the patient before we change therapy.
Is that something that we should be doing now with CLL?
And if so,
are we asking for a targeted panel, or how are we doing it?
Yep, so great question. The answer is absolutely yes.
We should be sequencing patients every time they relapse on therapy, whether it's a
continuous or a fixed-duration therapy.
There's actually a lot of commercial panels available, and now they pretty much all
include BTK and PLC gamma 2.
We have an institutional one we use as well as many other places do that also
generally will include these. And then some of the bigger
companies that have very large panels, they always have these on their panels as
well.
Okay. Lovely. Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Okay, so we're going to move on to myeloma
to close this session. Just before I start it, I want to
bring to everybody's attention the Hematological Working Group's
town hall meeting. That's on Monday night at
6:30. It's in combination with the
Chemistry and Cancer Research Working Group, and it's a much more
informal
kind of atmosphere, and they're going to be talking about some of the new drugs and
new targets in heme malignancy. So everybody's welcome to come to that.
Okay. So let's talk a little bit about
multiple myeloma.
Okay.
I'm not doing very well with moving them forward.
You can go back one.
I'll use the pen. Okay. All right. So these are my disclosures.
Okay, so what I want to concentrate on is two slightly different areas.
One,
to use our high-throughput technologies
to identify potential new targets, and then the second
area is really following on a little bit from what Jen has been saying about some
of the resistance mechanisms and how this may
inform our sequencing of therapies.
So just to get everybody up to speed, we all know that
myeloma is the clinical condition of
having malignant plasma cells in the bone marrow, where patients are going to
present with bone symptoms, anemia, high
calcium renal problems, and so on, and this is going to require
treatment.
But we also have two precursor conditions, smoldering
myeloma and MGUS, which are more benign in nature,
although they are able to move forward and progress to myeloma, and they're
actually incredibly common in the
population. So about 3% of patients over the age or
individuals over the age of 50 will have monoclonal
gammopathy, and that increases to about 10% of
individuals over the age of
85.So our
treatments for myeloma have dramatically improved over the
last few years, and now we're actually
talking about the concept of cure, but also talking
about long remissions of somewhere between
10 and 15 years. And this has really been based on a
number of different factors. Two of our very
well-utilized drugs actually target the
plasma cell machinery and
either going after the proteasome inhibitor or some of our
signaling pathways. On top of this, we also are
combining those drugs with a monoclonal antibody
against a ubiquitously expressed
antigen, CD38.
The last couple of years, we've been able to
harness some of the power of the immunotherapy world,
and we now have a number of bispecific antibodies as well as CAR
T-cell approaches, really going for
cell surface target of BCMA and
GPRC5D. And the latest kind of thing that has
moved in this direction is the use of trispecific
antibodies going after a number of these different surface
molecules. However, what's become really quite clear
is that despite all of these advances, we still have about 20%
of patients who we would consider high risk, who
still unfortunately have a very short progression-free survival.
So although we've made a dramatic improvement, we really haven't solved
the problem.
And so as we've gone through these different
technologies, we've clearly learned a lot about our biology,
and I want to concentrate on some of the things we've learned from our
next-generation sequencing today.
So we've been able, with the next gen sequencing and a number of our other
technologies, to put a bit of meat around the clinical progression
of myeloma. And we know that we have some initial events
which lead to the initiation of the disease, such as
translocations involving the immunoglobulin heavy chain gene,
and hyperdiploidy. Then as the disease progresses
and we come to the clinical stages, we know that there
is an increase in the number of copy number abnormalities.
There's a number of structural variants, including
chromoplexy and chromothripsis.
We have a lot of acquired mutations and then obviously,
a number of epigenetic changes.
And so some of our initial work was really looking at
whole exome sequencing, trying to determine the mutational
profile of myeloma plasma cells. And you can see
here that there are actually quite a large number of
genes which are mutated. But I think the thing that stands
out is that KRAS, NRAS,
and BRAF, so members of the RAS pathway, are actually
mutated in approximately 50% of patients with
KRAS and NRAS being in about 20% to 25%, and
BRAF in 4%.
But when you look at the sites of these mutations, they're actually slightly
different to many of our solid tumors.
And so it's not that we have a predominance of one
specific codon. And so you can see the size of
the circles here are representing the frequency of
these mutations in our patient set.
And yes, we have G12D, but we also have
GTELV, G13D, but a number of other
G13s as well, for instance. And so this results
in a number of difficulties when we think about how we're going to
target this drug. And when you think about it, it's
50% of patients, but we don't see a RAS inhibitor on that
slide that I showed you before, which I think is quite interesting and telling.
So what
else do we know about these mutations?
We know that they increase as the disease progresses.
And actually, if you look at smoldering myeloma, one
of the main abnormalities, which is able
to predict whether the patient with smoldering myeloma is going to be
able to go on to develop myeloma, is
the presence of a KRAS mutation. And that comes out highly
significant when we look at some of the other well-known factors,
such as the IMWG scoring system for the
development of myeloma.
The other thing we know that is that RAS mutations are very much involved in drug
resistance, and this is just some work performed by Bob
Lowenski's group,
showing that if patients have evidence of
a RAS mutation, they are much more resistant to proteasome
inhibitors, one of our central therapies.
So going back, why has this not been a drug that has kind of
made it to or a target that's made it to prime time?
So, 10 years ago, we started to look at this,
and this is just some work looking at one of the
FDA-approved inhibitors. And you can see in a
group of myeloma patients that, yes, many of the
patients did respond exceptionally well to the drug, even
patients with had evidence of extramedullary disease.
However, unfortunately, the response was
incredibly short-lived.
And people have gone on to look at this in a little bit more detail.
This is just some similar data using the BRAF inhibitor,
again, showing very good evidence of disease response.
But again, the disease relapsed relatively
quickly.And the German group were able to
do a clinical study combining both a BRAF inhibitor with a
MEK inhibitor. And again, many of those patients had a
great response, but the response was relatively
short-lived at six months. And when they went on to look, it
was because of the emergence of RAS mutations,
as we've been hearing previously with the BTK
inhibitor mutations.
So we decided to take a slightly different look at this, and
rather than targeting RAS with a
therapy
or a kinase inhibitor, we decided to try and target one
of the processes that RAS is involved in.
And so that's macropinocytosis, okay, which is
essentially this non-specific endocytic process
by which a cell is able to
internalize extracellular fluids.
And it turns out that for
RAS-driven cancers, this process is incredibly
important, enabling them to gain their nutrient supply
and to proliferate in a
usually nutrient-sparse environment.
And what happens is that the
stimulation of the RAS leads to
some actin remodeling, which then results in the
formation of your macropinosome, and then this
is able to bring in the nutrients into the
cell. And so,
along with Dr. Barsagi's group at NYU, the hypothesis
was that if you are a RAS-mutated
cell, you undergo this macropinocytosis,
taking in these extracellular fluids.
And the theory would be that if you could actually
target or add on a targeted treatment
to these extracellular fluids, you may be able
to get a selective uptake into your
mutant RAS cell, whereas your wild-type cell won't
be using macropinocytosis, and therefore, potentially,
you won't get any nonspecific uptake of your
chemical. And there was a very nice review written about
this, which I think
makes me laugh as an approach of exploiting
cancer's drinking problem.
So what did the team in the lab did? They decided
to make a monobody with a drug
payload. Now, we all have been using antibody drug
conjugates in the clinic. They're actually quite large
molecules with a payload. The difference here
is that the monobody is actually incredibly small and therefore
can be taken up by this macropinocytosis approach.
And so one of the other things about this as well
is that this would not only potentially improve its toxicity profile
because it wouldn't get taken up into non-RAS cells, but it would
also give a potential for being able to
deliver more drug than you may be able to with an
ADC technology.
And so we were able to form
our actual drug, but then also we developed
one that would be with Cy 5 on it so that we could trace it in the
cells.
And so this is just an example. Clearly, one of the first things you need to know
is whether myeloma cells actually do use
macropinocytosis. And so we looked at this both in
NRAS and KRAS mutant cells. And in this
first slide, thing in the green, these are examples
of
a macropinocytosis marker.
And then
in the red in the middle set of cells is our
marker
of our nanobody labeled. And you can see
that
they are taken up into the mutant RAS cells.
Importantly, we are able to demonstrate that this doesn't just occur in
myeloma for those mutant RAS things, but it's also potentially going to be
useful for a number of other diseases such as pancreatic cancer,
colon, and lung.
And so we went on to use a myeloma mouse model
and can clearly demonstrate that
the nanobody does not affect growth if you have wild
type
myeloma. But if you have KRAS myeloma
or you have NRAS, then it is able to
affect the growth of the cells. And I apologize, these two bars
are the wrong way around, but you do definitely see a
decrease in tumor size
with this therapy.
And maybe importantly, you don't see or you see very little
off-target effect suggesting that this is an appropriate
approach.
So hopefully moving forward, we may now have an approach that
would be feasible for
a number of RAS-mutated cancers, which is not just
dependent on the tyrosine kinase and also importantly is not
just dependent on the codon of the tyrosine kinase.
And we've been working with a company called
Tescat to move this forward into the clinic.
Okay. So back to other
things that have
helped us to identify approaches using high throughput
screening.As I mentioned, we're now in an era
of immunotherapy where we're using bispecific
antibodies and CAR Ts, and we have two relatively
new targets to the myeloma world, BCMA and
GPRC5D. And certainly, with our
bispecifics in the relapse setting, we have been
having progression-free survivals of over a
year, and now these have been moved up into earlier lines of
therapy. The impact seems to be much
stronger.
However, what we have been finding is that there is antigen
escape and that patients do relapse.
Now, initially, the thought process was that maybe this was
mainly because of T cell exhaustion,
rather than being something inherent to the actual myeloma
cell itself. But some lovely work done by our
colleagues in Calgary,
Nizar and Paola, as well as some of colleagues in Germany, have
shown that it's actually very common to
down-regulate BCMA expression itself.
And so in the group of patients that the Calgary
group looked at, 65% of patients actually
relapsed due to BCMA antigen escape.
Now, that could either be because of biallelic deletions
or because of a monoallelic deletion, and then a
deletion in one of the binding sites of the antibody in
the extracellular domain. And so there's been
some more recent work
that has suggested that maybe the
mutations you get in that extracellular domain
may depend on which bispecific antibody you are
using,
and therefore suggesting that it may be that we can
cycle through the bispecific antibodies, or indeed,
if a patient has blocked the bispecific
antibody binding site, that it may be that we could swap to a
CAR T-cell approach. And these kind of different
mutations are not only for BCMA, but have also been shown
in the GPRC5D series of experiments as
well.
And so a recent paper
from the Wurzburg group actually went on to look
at
patients who had received all of the,
what is it, HEPA refractory patients, so all of the seven groups
of drugs that we're commonly using in myeloma.
And what they were suggesting was that in about half of the patients,
they had already lost one of the targets that we quite
frequently used. And so therefore, if you had already lost that
target, maybe rechallenging that patient with the same target
was not going to be appropriate. Whereas, for instance, if you still
had that target present, it may be possible to
rechallenge these patients. And so that was,
to some extent, a little bit about one of my questions to Jen there,
because in the myeloma world, we haven't really moved on a
clinical basis past the use of FISH.
And so we very much do our diagnosing with FISH, but we haven't
particularly moved on from there to thinking
about how we can use all of this next gen sequencing data
in the clinic.
There are a number of different groups now which are
trying to utilize this data, and this is just an example
from Brian Walker's group, where he's developed
a NGS panel
which is used in the CLIA lab at his
institution. And essentially,
what he's managed to do is to combine those
things that we would want at diagnosis with respect to
knowing a little bit more about the myeloma.
So be that some of the high risk abnormalities we
would want to know, such as the translocation group and their
P53 status and the status of 1q and 1p.
But also to be able to look a little more into the
details about our IgH translocations.
And we know that,
for instance, 25% of patients will have an 11;14
translocation, and this will be very
sensitive to venetoclax, and Larry Boyes is going
to be talking about this, I think, on Monday.
But also there's a number of publications in the poster sessions here
about the potential use of NSD2 inhibitors, of
which myeloma would be a good place for
because
we do have a large number of patients that have a 4;14
translocation. But as I say, in addition to all of that, these
panels are able to detect mutations, but maybe more
importantly in this era of our immunotherapies,
they're also able to detect some of these treatment-resistant
mutations, particularly those around 38,
BCMA, and GPRC5D. So I think this is
something that is really going to move the clinical field
forward as we all get used to moving away from FISH and
actually embracing these modern technologies as the CLL
world and the AML world have done prior to us.
So in conclusion, what I hope I've shown you is an example of
how high throughput screening has identified a
potential new target,
and given you some ideas about how we can potentially
use RAS in myeloma. But I also
hope I've spent a little bit of time discussing some of
the maybe reasons why we should start doing
sequencing generally in myeloma to help us
with guiding our immunotherapy selection.
So thank you very
much.Okay.
Hello.
Hello again.
I was wondering if
specifically these RAS mutations increase
the
vulnerability of these cancer cells to
macropinocytosis at a much higher rate compared to other normal
cells, then maybe this could be positioned
as a vulnerability beyond delivering
what
you guys are interested in, and perhaps be expanded to
nanoparticles, let's say, and other
therapeutic molecules.
Yeah. So no, I completely agree. We've been doing it with a way
to deliver, and we chose MMAEs. It's very
traditional, I can say, well-utilized
approach. But I completely agree.
I think it would be, in actual fact, using some of these
more modern approaches to deliver newer kind of
target drugs would be very helpful and useful. So yes.
Thank you. And just a quick follow-up, and perhaps even expanding it
to other RAS-driven cancers. We're talking lung
cancer and others, which probably would also have
this kind of vulnerability to very high levels of
macropinocytosis, right?
Yeah. So,
as part of the work when we submitted the paper, some
of the work we've just finished was to show some of the uses in other
cancers. And so, we have a very nice pancreatic model in the
mouse that it works beautifully in. Yeah.
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, so
wonderful lecture. I enjoyed it. Very interesting and logical.
I'm Mike Wong from MD Anderson. So my question
for you is that there's some breakthroughs of some hot
KRAS inhibitors in pancreatic cancer.
They may be targeting with a special mutation or some.
But have you tried it in myeloma, and
what do you think about it?
Yeah. So, at the moment, we haven't tried that particular one.
We've been looking at some of the RAS
on inhibitors,
and they do seem to work, and so we're
exploring that as well. So I do think that's a potential
good approach. Obviously, myeloma is relatively rare, and so we're
working on some of these companies to
proceed with some of those in the clinic.
Thanks.
Thank you for a good talk. Going back to talking about the loss of key
therapeutic genes and how we have about this 50/50
split between patients that are still susceptible to prior lines of therapies,
what about the concept of spatial heterogeneity and subclones?
How do we have this sort of assurance that we are adequately
sampling all of the disease within the body and making sure that there are not
subclones that may be more or less vulnerable to escape from one or more of these
therapies?
No, I think you're completely correct.
I didn't go into that.
But certainly, there is a lot of data, particularly when we
were using some of these drugs in that relapse setting,
is that we know that the spatial
environment is really important.
And we've, in the past, have done a lot of work comparing bone marrow biopsies
to
other sites, and that is one of our key challenges, which is
why in the long term, having something that targets a truncal
mutation is theoretically going to be much more
beneficial. But yes. I think I would also say that the
German group, who have really much led this area, have recently
shown that it's not just spatial as in bone marrow
versus an extramedullary site. There's actually a lot of
differences within the different niches within a bone marrow sample
itself. So yes, an ongoing issue that we have.
Thank you.
Hi, thank you for the talk. I have a quick question.
So the amount of treatments we have today, what do you
think is the best way to use them,
synergistically or otherwise, to minimize the
cancer's ability to mutate, like forcing reliance on a certain target,
something like that?
Yeah, no, that's a great question, and I was going to
say one of the things we've always done in myeloma is
felt that
the more drugs we can put in a combination, the better.
But clearly, at some point, the patient has too many side effects,
and that's just not possible. And so I think one of the things now
is trying to get the deepest response
we can. So trying to get the deepest MRD we can,
and then probably peeling back at that point so that we
don't develop those resistances that you're talking about.
So yeah.
Thank you.
Hi. I'm really interested in this targeting
macropinocytosis globally, and I'm just wondering if you
can speak to any of the side effects more specifically, because
I feel like there's some healthy drinkers in the body,
macrophages, dendritic cells. Do you see any specific
neutropenia, thrombocytopenia?
So we've
only been in
mouse models so far, and
there's some early work in some other animal models, and so far,
we haven't seen any other issues than,
as you say, you might expect to see some issues with
some of your scavenger cells, for want of a better expression.
But so far, we haven't seen any.
Good luck.
Last question. Yeah, since there's a lot of questions about
RAS, I've been having this conversation with Brian Walker actually about,
they're not the first mutations that
happen in myeloma, but they are
maybe linked to progression, and in the first talk about AML,
they often are late subclonal mutations.
So by targeting RAS as compared to pancreas cancer
or something, are we going to be able to see deep
responses? I wonder your take on that and...
So I think my take would probably come back to one of the questions
earlier. I don't think that we would be targeting RAS as a
single kind of treatment. I think we're going to be
needing to do it in
some form of combination. But there's no ifs or buts.
As the disease progresses, this RAS
becomes one of the major drivers of that progression, and so
therefore, we do need to do something about it.
But I can't ever imagine it would be a single
treatment.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Excellent. Well, thank you everybody for joining us.
It's been a real pleasure to see everybody, and we will
catch up over the coming days. Thank you.